all right welcome back everyone to my
round seven recap from Buell I had a
really interesting game today and I
actually finished a couple hours ago but
I had a bad headache after the game so I
took some rest and now I'm a little bit
more awake and ready to share what was a
really interesting battle so I was
playing International Master rohith
Krishna from India and coming into this
game I didn't really know what to expect
because my opponent has played knife 3
and E4 and D4 in the past so I was
really just coming in with an open mind
and ready for a fight and he opted for
Pawn D4 and we went into a Queen's
Gambit declined and most people these
days who I encounter take on D5 right
away but my opponent opted for Bishop G5
which is definitely a playable line
leaving the tension in the center I
played C6 it's a solid move creating the
semi-slav setup and after E3 I played
Knight b87 and then he takes on D5 so
we're essentially getting a queen scam
declined exchange variation but from a
slightly delayed move order
and after Bishop to D3 I wanted to put
the bishop on D6 but this wouldn't be as
good now Bishop D6 was a setup I played
in my third round game but in that game
I wasn't committed to Knight bd7 and
there's cases in these Bishop D6 lines
where the Knight likes to maneuver to A6
C7 and E6
so I ended up going for a more
traditional setup here with Bishop t7
very simply breaking the pin of the
knights and I can quickly turn on the uh
the database we can see that this
position has occurred over 3000 times in
Master Level play and my opponent played
the main line Queen to C2 and I play the
move here which I discovered many years
ago and it's a move that just attempts
to be very solid for black is Knight to
H5
and this is still very much within the
realm of opening Theory and the idea of
this move is simply to force a trade of
the darksword Bishops given that the
Knight is controlling F4 so Bishop 4
doesn't make any sense for whites and
there's really no other place for this
bishop to hide so we do trade he takes
on E7 I take back with the queen and he
plays Knight ge2 now I was remembering a
small trap here that if white plays
Knight F3 pretty sure there's a strong
move Knight F4 this has been played in
Master Level play but it's a nice idea
to exploit the the pin on e-file and
hits the bishop and the G2 pawn and this
I think would be very comfortable for
black to play going into the middle game
but that didn't happen because he plays
Knight E2 breaking the pin and
preventing any Knight F4 ideas
so here I play Knight to B6 and I'll
admit that I wasn't in specific
preparation but I knew a general setup
for Black basically to put the Knight
here put the bishop here and then
depending Which Way White Castles I'm
gonna basically Castle the same way as
white so if White Castle's King side all
eventually castle kingside if White
Castle's Queen side I'll go for the the
queen side castling as well and what
happened is White Castle queenside and I
go for Bishop E6 H3 and Castle queenside
myself so it's pretty rare that we get a
an opening where both players Queensland
Castle but it does happen and in this
case we're basically done with opening
and approaching the middle game and I
kind of have to sneeze this is probably
a good time to run an ad wait now I
don't have to sneeze ah
I have been uh suffering from some
allergies the weather has been very good
here but uh yeah I'm allergic to
something maybe maybe I'm allergic to
both players casting Queen side what to
do okay no sneeze happening what was I
saying so we both Castle Queen side
we're approaching the middle game and
from here my opponent plays Pawn G4 so
very clear that white wants to grab
space on the king side I have nothing
better than to retreat to F6 and then he
plays Pawn to F3 which is a flexible
move it's Solid 5 G4 also creates ideas
of later playing E4 and I played my next
move relatively quickly King to B8 which
is a very flexible move and almost
always a king is just preferable on the
B8 Square no longer aligned with the
White Queen
and then my opponent quickly responds
with King B1 so doing the same idea and
then I play the move Pawn to H5 so I'm
trying to exert pressure on the king
side and perhaps give white some
questions of what to do with the g-pod
and there are cases where I do want to
take and then open the H file I was also
thinking maybe later of playing Bishop
to C8 on Mission Queen tits the epon so
white does have to be a little bit
careful here and he ended up playing the
move Pawn to G5 which does look like the
most uh testing move questioning where
I'm going to put my knight from F6 and I
Retreat to the E8 Square which at first
looks really ugly but I figured that the
knights is actually gonna be pretty
happy on the d6wear where it combines
really nicely with this Pawn structure
and for anyone that plays the Queen's
game decline this is a useful maneuver
to keep in mind like whenever you can
get a knight to D6 then it can control a
lot of key Central squares and I believe
we call this Knight the Kappa block of
knights pretty sure capablanca was known
for doing this type of thing in various
metal games
so here my opponent plays H4 I achieve
my Kappa Blanca Knights and then he
plays Pawn to E4 so things are very much
heating up and it looks like white is
just grabbing space like last several
moves light's been expanding with the
pawns but I'm coping with the squares
that I have and I decided to go for
Knight to C4 which just seems to put the
most amount of pressure on whites not
only having ideas of Knight E3 with a
fork but also unleashing my queen to
potentially come to B4 and there's ideas
of Queen B4 and Knight A3 if White's not
careful achieving the pin and the fork
so this is a potential pork so white
does have to be very very careful now
given all the scary arrows and he played
the safe move Queen C1 ensuring that I
can't come in to E3 but I respond with
pontic Z4 and after F takes E4 I find a
really nice Square for my Bishop on G4
pinning the Knight to the rook and even
though white has two Center pawns and I
have zero Center pawns I was feeling
very good good just given the placement
of my pieces my Bishop is Rock Solid
defended by the H Pawn my knight
supported
um I have Superfluous Knights which in
this case are a pretty nice thing and I
also have the two half open Center files
that I can use to exert pressure against
White Center Pawns
so I was feeling good and going forward
from here my opponent played King A1
which I wasn't fully expecting but I
think it's a logical move um definitely
the safest Square on the board for the
king
and in this position I play the move
which at first looks very risky but I
was very happy with it once I considered
it and also when I eventually played it
is a move Pawn to C5
and it looks risky because I'm conceding
these squares and allowing potential for
the Knight to come in I'm also giving
white time to try and exploit my knight
which is attacked by the bishop and also
could potentially be attacked by the
queen but the reason why I played C5 is
it's a way to try and just break apart
White Center and I'm putting immediate
pressure against the D4 pawn and keep in
mind the knights pinned so I'm
threatening to take on D4 and another
goal was just to remove the pawn from
controlling E5 so if white plays D5 here
I would very happily plot my Knights on
E5 Square where it's just a really nice
post and it's very hard for white to
remove and meanwhile these pawns are
pretty much fixed on the light squares
which does not combine well for a white
Side Square Bishop so after I played C5
my opponent took a relatively long think
and ended up playing the move Knight to
B5 now when I initially played C5 I knew
that Knight B5 was an option but I
didn't look at it so closely until it
actually came on the board and it is a
kind of scary looking move at first
because not only is white threatening to
take the knights given that there's
another attacker but White's also
getting the knight in and basically
threatening Queen F4 check and if I'm
not careful I could walk into some like
windmill ideas with a queen and the
Knights but thankfully in this position
I have to move Pawn to Asics which
attacks the knights and creates a little
bit more Luft for my king and now the
ball is back in White's courts because
if the Knight moves like if it moves
back to C3 White's accomplished nothing
and I just win the pawn on D4 and
meanwhile if white plays Queen on four
check I simply move back to A8 and if he
goes in for the check I play King A7 and
I think the Knight would have gone in a
little bit too deep here yeah it looks
really messy Like A lot's going on but
I'm pretty sure Bach is in very good
shape in this position
so rather than going for that line my
opponent took on C4 here and after I
take back he then plays Queen F4 I play
King 8 and then he retreats to C3 so
this is a good sign that my opponent
didn't really make much use of the
Knight coming to B5 had to move back and
in this position it looks like I'm very
close to winning the D4 Pawn uh given
the pressure that the bishop is still
exerting also I have two attackers
against D4 but it's not super simple
given that after I take he takes back
with rook and everything appears to be
defended for white
but I chose to go into this line because
there's a way to just make continual
threats and I play my next move Queen to
B4 simply threatening made in one but
not only that I'm aligning with the Rook
on D4 and very soon we're gonna see the
the tactic for black after he Retreats
with Queen C1 I take on D4 he takes back
and then I take on B2 and I took some
time to go into this but I figured that
this wins a clean Pawn after he takes
and I take the Knight and I'm up a pawn
and it seemed like a position which I
have very good chances to win because
we're pretty much in the end game as
well but to my opponent's credit he
found some very resourceful counter play
and he started with a move Rook to B1
here taking advantage of the newly half
open B file for lights and now it's
white who's threatening made in one
against my b-pawn and when I saw this
position from a distance I thought that
I would end up playing Pawn to B5
but I couldn't gather myself to play it
because it just looks so weakening to my
king and
um yeah I was scared of ideas of Queen
A3 during the game I have since tracked
with the engine and apparently Queen A3
can be met with King B7 and black is
completely fine here but even if I did
play B5 it's not that simple for Vach
because white has Knight D5 which I
think would be likely to go into some
end game after the trade of queens and
it would take a ton of work for black to
try and win but rather than playing B5
and exposing my king I decided on what
looked like a safer move Rook to B8
and here my opponent goes for Knight T5
essentially forcing the queen trade of
course I want to take the pawn but it's
gotta be way too risky like Knights B6
King A7 Queen F2
looks terrifying because now it's my
king who is in trouble and yeah I just
didn't want to mess with this it's
actually easy for black to plunder made
here like Queen F3 thinking I'm stopping
the discoveries walks into this move
double check and then Queen A7 mate so
going back I eventually realized that I
do have to trade Queens I take on B2 he
takes back with King and in this
position I played my next move
relatively quickly not even taking more
than a minute King A7 the reason why I
played this so quickly is because I
assumed that the Knight is eventually
going to give a check and my king is
just more useful on a square where it
can't immediately be checked by the
knights
but after this move he played Rook F1
and then there starts to be some
annoying counter play for whites given
that my F Pawn is a Target and I played
the natural move to defend it but then
he has this very annoying move Knight F4
and while I don't want to allow is for
the position to simplify too much and
he's threatening to win the pawn on each
five he's also threatening to win my
Bishop
and I think what I originally wanted to
play here was Bishop
C4 but I couldn't quite make it work
like he has this move and then my bishop
and pawn are still attacked
so instead I chose to repeat the
position I moved back to G4 he moves
back to D5 and then I play the move Rook
E8 so this is one way to avoid the
repetition and keep the game going and
the idea with this move is I'm trying to
get a beneficial trade where if he takes
the pawn I was calculating takes takes
and then Bishop E6 after which I'm
hitting the knights and hitting the pawn
and I thought there'd be like decent
chances to play for a win from here if
he plays Knight C7 I have Bishop C4
eventually I'm going to take on each
form and generally in these situations
the bishop is more useful than the
knights because it can both defend
against White's past pawn and also
assist on the queen side like there's
always ideas of eventual Rook H2 and
then perhaps winning A2
unfortunately we didn't go into any of
this because rather than taking on F7 my
opponent played just a very solid move
Rook F4 and this move simply defends the
pawn and puts the question what is vlak
doing next and I took a long time here
trying to figure out how I can
potentially play for a win but I
couldn't come up with anything so clear
and I ended up playing the move Bishop
to E6 I do want to note my alternative
was King B8 the reason why I didn't go
for this is because now after takes
takes uh there's this move Knight F4 and
this was possible in the other line too
if my king was still on A7 but I didn't
want to risk potentially losing this
position even though I'm up a pawn here
it looked a little bit risky given that
I'm not easily winning H4 and white has
the idea of Knight G6 and then winning
G7 and defending H4 I think maybe if I
can still try and play for a win but it
just didn't seem so clear and I played
Bishop E6 given that it's a much safer
option but after he plays Knight C7 the
position liquidates very quickly I play
Rook E7 he takes I take he takes on F7 I
take on e4 he takes on G7 I take on H4
and yeah the more pawns that come off
the board the closer we get to a draw
eventually we do trade the pawns on the
king side
and I was considering offering a draw
right away but I figured I'd at least
try a little bit there's no risk for
black but we're gonna see that I didn't
really make any progress my one hope was
to at some point try and trade Rooks for
example after I played Rook T6 if white
takes then I'm pretty sure this was a
winning King Pawn ending because it's
some weird like distant opposition you
can check with the table base oh no King
C2 is drawn
ah
ah because if you're then King D2 and I
can't actually make progress without
allowing whites to get the opposition
so yeah even my my one hope of trading
Rooks still needs to have drawn ending
but yeah from my opponent's perspective
he is just safer keeping the Rook on the
board and yeah we played a handful of
more moves
and I made no progress
and eventually yeah my opponent started
checking me I ran to A6 but after King
B3 I didn't want to torture my opponent
or torture myself anymore and we agreed
to withdraw after I played Rook to G3
check
so overall I think it was a pretty solid
game on my part I don't think I was ever
worse in this game
and I do want to show the overall engine
analysis of this game
um it's just switch tabs here we can see
that actually from both of us it was
incredibly clean my opponent did make
two inaccuracies but according to leecha
stockfish I made known accuracies no
mistakes no blunders maybe there were
some points where I could have put a bit
more pressure but I mean given that I
played 97 accuracy in this game I really
don't have too many complaints and uh
yeah kudos to my opponent for defending
what seemed to be a tricky position
so
um yeah uh it was a tiring game
um it took over four hours and
even though it's one game a day these
games are draining and I think it
requires a lot of just mental and
physical stamina to get through the
tournament without getting too fatigued
so I do appreciate those watching until
the end of the recap if you have
questions or comments leave them below
or if you just want to wish me luck in
the next round leave your good luck
wishes below and do stay tuned for the
final three rounds I'm currently four
out of seven so on a plus one score I'll
probably be playing a high rated
opponent next round as well so stay
tuned and I'll see you guys in the next
one